what's next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person
brittany
britney spears is officially free from
her 13-year-long conservatorship
on friday attorneys for the pop star
returned to court where a los angeles
judge ruled to terminate the
conservatorship that has controlled her
career and finances for nearly 14 years
i will say that brittany has been put
into a position
through our collaboration in the work of
my law firm
to succeed
we have a safety net in place for
brittany both on the personal side
and on the financial side as those of
you who are in court understand
but brittany as of today
is a free woman
and she's an independent woman
and the rest with her support system
will be up to brittany the hearing was
the first since her father jamie spears
was removed as a co-conservator so jody
montgomery is currently the conservator
of the person she took over as we know
from brittany's father jamie some time
ago
the conservatorship over the estate or
the finances is someone selected by
brittany's current attorney matthew
rosengard so it is someone that is very
favorable to attorney to brittany and is
working with her brittany celebrated the
news by sharing this video to her
instagram her fans cheering over the
termination she wrote in part quote best
day ever
[Music]
[Applause]
earlier this week in a since-deleted
caption on instagram the 39-year-old
singer wrote that this week would be
quote very interesting for her adding
quote i haven't prayed for something
more in my life my dad may have started
the conservatorship but what people
don't know is that it is my mom who gave
him the idea i will never get back those
years i think the conservatorship is
going to be over today but the story
certainly is not leading up to friday's
court hearing e.t spoke to tamar armanek
an attorney familiar with
conservatorship cases and she explained
how britney's conservatorship went on
for so long i think that the
conservatorship was appropriate in 2008
i think what we were all looking at was
someone in dire straits really needing
people around her to come in and help
her
and that's what happened and that's what
occurred what ended up happening is this
became a very drawn out conservatorship
a conservative ship where the people
around her began profiting off of her
work
her sweat equity
and it became about something else it
became more about control
rather than actually getting brittany
well and now that the conservatorship is
officially over tamar detailed what
britney's life will look like now she
can paint her kitchen cabinets she can
marry her fiance tomorrow if she would
like she can make decisions on if she
wants to buy a handbag if she wants to
take a trip to hawaii if she wants to
see her children take them to disneyland
all of those things are going to be up
to her
[Music]
you